esta vez ha dibujado aquí el área bajo
la curva de fx por encima del eje x
desde el punto x igual am hasta el punto
x igual que por cierto habíamos dicho
que se denota justo así es decir la
integral definida desde a hasta bbb fx
de x y en esta ocasión lo que quiero
hacer es introducir un nuevo punto un
nuevo valor para x que esté entre estos
dos valores am y vamos a decir que lo
voy a llamar se y bueno ojo este valor
de s puede ser igual a o en su dado caso
podría ser igual a b o podría estar en
medio de ellos así que déjame ponerlo
por aquí se me ocurre que sea este valor
de equipo que este va a ser nuestro
valor de cm antes de poner que este es
el ok de lujo y vamos a escribir aquí
que a es menor o igual hace que su vez
es menor o igual a b
ok
y lo que quiero hacer en este momento es
pensar qué es lo que va a pasar con esta
integral que tengo aquí y la integral
tomada desde el punto
hasta el punto ce y la integral tomada
desde el punto c hasta el punto b hay
que pensar un poco en ello
así que me quiero fijar y déjenme
cambiar de color a este de aquí en la
integral en la integral ok
desde el valor de amd hasta el valor de
s de bueno fx cdx ok de equis y recuerda
que esto es lo que representa es el área
bajo la curva desde a hasta hacer es
decir esta área que tengo aquí esta área
que tengo aquí es lo que me representa
houston esta integral que tengo am de
color verde esta de aquí y bueno después
nos vamos a tomar am la integral la
integral desde el valor de cm hasta el
valor debe de amd fx de fx de x y bueno
de la misma manera podemos pensar o
podemos darnos cuenta que es el área
bajo la curva desde el valor de s hasta
el valor debe es decir todo esto que
tengo aquí esta parte que tengo aquí y
seguramente lo primero que te brinca y
de hecho de una manera visual es que tal
vez es que el área entera desde a hasta
vez que tenemos justo aquí es
exactamente igual que la suma de éstas
áreas nuevas del área de color verde y
del área de color azul es decir que está
integral es exactamente igual que la
suma de estas dos y bueno de nuevo lo
primero que me vas a preguntar es mira
está muy padre esto pero para qué es
útil esta propiedad es decir que si
encontramos un valor para hacer que sea
mayor o igual que hay menor o igual que
vemos entonces para qué es útil a
dividir está integral de esta manera y
bueno seguramente lo primero que se te
ocurre es que esto es muy útil si
tenemos funciones discontinuas o si
hablamos por ejemplo de funciones
escalonadas porque podemos tomar la
integral completa como pequeñas
integrales como la suma de pequeñas
integrales o bueno se me ocurre que en
otro momento en donde es muy útil esto
que tengo aquí es cuando quiero probar
el teorema fundamental del cálculo y
bueno de hecho está esta propiedad que
tengo aquí de las integrales es bastante
importante de hecho te estás dando
cuenta que es una técnica bastante útil
así que si por ejemplo a déjame dibujar
aquí otros nuevos ejes am se me ocurre
tomarnos así voy a dibujar aquí
y aquí voy a dibujar a otro eje ok antes
de poner que son ejes ok esté por aquí
este por aquí y ahora imagínate que am
aquí esta x aquí está james y aquí me
tomo el valor de amd ok y por acá me
tomo el valor de b y me tomo la
siguiente función vamos a pensar en una
función escalonada por aquí por aquí
imagínate que la función se ve más o
menos así imagínate que estoy hablando
de una función constante es más vamos a
seguir un poco con esto ok y mediante
que llegamos hasta este punto y después
que esta función llega hasta este punto
y se mantiene constante algo más o menos
así de lujo y entonces puedes decir que
esta área entera la podemos dividir en
dos a déjame ponerla justo así tenemos
aquí una parte ok aquí tengo otra parte
ok y bueno am aquí tenemos la
discontinuidad y después
llegó hasta este valor de aquí y bueno
toda esta área que tengo representada
aquí en todo esto que tengo aquí
representado lo podemos dividir en dos
esta área la podemos separar y dejar de
utilizar este color
2 áreas más pequeñas en esta primera que
tengo justo aquí ok y después también
nos podemos fijar en esta otra pequeña
área que tengo aquí la puedo separar en
dos
utilizando esta propiedad de las
integrales